all right we're going to turn now to
this is also a good deal Kelly Ripa
she's a media Powerhouse many of you
will know her for her work on over more
than three decades she burst onto the
scene as Haley Vaughn and all my
children that was back in 1990 and for
the past 20 plus years she's been the
Emmy award-winning co-host of the talk
show live there she is with Kelly and
Ryan now she's releasing a book it's
called Live Wire long-winded short
stories so we talked to Kelly Ripa the
other day about writing deeply personal
essays for the book and everything else
from motherhood to her relationship with
Regis Philbin and her 26-year marriage
to Mark Consuelos who a lot of people
call smoking hot Mark she doesn't
disagree
it's a memoir but it's also based on
essays that you tell in your life where
we do get to hear your life story was
this hard for you to unpack your life
this way it it was and it would have
been smarter and easier to write a
memoir but I knew that I had something
to say that might be helpful might be
entertaining might make you think might
be a little provocative in certain ways
and may also just be an example that you
don't give up you should never give up
but I was surprised to learn because we
already mentioned the smoking hot Mark
Consuelos uh that you guys not only
eloped but five days before the
elopement there was a breakup
not only did he break up with me he
accused you of cheating he accused me of
cheating the nerve Kelly the nerve I
mean I was like in What scenario would I
be the one to cheat on you like hello
have you seen yourself this is what I
love about Mark it's as if he's never
passed a mirror it's as if he doesn't
know that he's smoking hot but you know
not only did he break up with me he cut
me off and then we wound up sort of
seeing each other for the first time
ironically in The Green Room at live
with Regis and Kathy Lee for a Mother's
Day special and you know and I say in
the book If We Had cell phones if cell
phones existed then
smartphones and apps we would never be
married today because you'd be on your
phone Gail said she loves the cover I do
too but I love the back but we're deep
readers we judge the cover
it's just very Fierce photo attitude
this bite-sized ball of fire and it
looks like a woman who has found her
voice looks like a woman who does
self-advocate thank you why is it
important for you to make sure you send
that message to people as a woman it is
hard for our voices to be heard without
being made to feel like we're being a
complainer or hysterical or emotional
and so we tend to put our needs and our
own self-advocacy aside we stuff it down
while rallying around everyone we know
we work with we live with and I don't
know a mother on an airplane that would
put her own oxygen mask that's gone
first yes she'd put on her kids her
husband's making sure people in the
aisle have theirs on and then slowly
just die from oxygener and that's them
every day I wouldn't even appreciate it
they wouldn't know I was dead Kelly the
chapter that I thought was really very
uh
touching to me was fool me once fool me
twice because you talked about your
relationship with Regis and how the show
ended and how you know Regis of course
is no longer with us it seems like he
wanted to set the record shape because
back then you were kind of vilified in
in terms of you know Regis was asked a
couple times have you been on the show
he did leave the impression that he was
never invited back on the show and that
there was bad blood and you said no that
really is not true no it's not true I
mean none of that was true and what was
so baffling to not just me but to us as
a show was that he'd been invited back
he'd been invited back to host I had
seen him
on camera and off camera and I wasn't
sure why a I was vilified and B why it
would be solely my responsibility to
maintain what was really just a working
relationship right we did not have this
close friendship that was assumed I have
still enormous respect for him and I
truly think he is still the greatest
Storyteller of all time and I loved
working with him I thought it was a
unique experience I learned so much
there was nobody like him but a line
that struck me when you said you know
women often take the high road that's
really code for shut the bleep up you
said yeah which I really think is true
and the lesson you learned from that it
seems to me is that correct the
narrative because so often we say look
just leave it alone if you give more
oxygen to it I was so desperate for it
to stop I didn't want to advance the
news cycle by addressing it but by not
addressing it I was vilified and and I
just felt it was so truly unfair and
untrue and again it's one of those
things that I found that I was a woman
being asked to answer for the behavior
of someone else but now we sit here
today you're in Mark it's a 26 year
marriage your empty nesters we are how
are you feeling you two you know we
really have discovered we took our first
vacation ever without children in 25
years really and it was incredible it
was magic and they're like falling in
love again it was like falling in love
again and so if you can really get to
the other side and people who are
married and who have young kids and are
in it
man you're speaking to Tony yeah you are
in it like we call it Peak life no
you're in Peak life but eventually and I
know it's shocking right now
they grow up and they leave the house
you will reconnect and fall in love all
over again and and that's when you get
those the feelings back in the pit of
your stomach you get it all it all comes
back like
wait a minute I remember I love sitting
I'm going to say something disgusting
sitting naked in the living room with
you not disgusting we've got thick
blinds you know what I mean my kids are
probably watching this and they're like
disgusted they're like that they're like
oh my gosh yeah my favorite
you know what I mean like you can sit
around the house as you were before of
course
you've told great stories but at the end
it's such a great reflection of your
life and who you are and you wrote it
too it's great congratulations Kelly
Ripa author thank you so much thank you
that is a nice ring to it though it does
yes
thank you the name of the book is
Livewire it's on sale wherever you like
to buy your books right now